I try to hear everything that's
happening and that that can be very very
difficult and and someone who tells you
oh I hear everything that's happening on
stages line because there's there's
almost no way I think to really do that
but as an exercise I do try to identify
okay what is that musician the third
flute playing and I try to make sure I
can hear that but you have to hear
what's going on because if you're
there's a way I've used the analogy it's
like it's like a ball a very big ball
you can affect the way the ball rolls
and you can change the direction that
the ball is rolling if it's already in
is if it's already in motion but you
can't suddenly have it turn an abrupt
angle there's a natural way that the
ball can be guided so even though you're
steering the ball there's a natural
momentum that the ball has that you
can't interfere with so if the orchestra
has a certain flow you can affect the
flow but there's a natural way to do
that and there's a way that actually
would interrupt the natural flow so it's
not that you can just do whatever you
want you have to take into account what
is happening on what is being offered
from the player so that means really
being in touch with what they're doing
and hearing them as well as you can and
it's surprisingly difficult to really
identify not even with two or three or
four lines but even just one line to
really hear what the the will and the
and the sense that the players are
giving to one line to really listen to
them to actually be able to react to it
in a meaningful ways is surprisingly
difficult
well that's difficult and and what
happens is if there's more than one
current if their conflicting currents on
stage then you have to make a choice you
have to either give in or insist and for
the other musicians on stage if they
sense two currents if they say for
example if I show one thing and they
hear a response to that that is not in
sync then they have a dilemma they have
to choose do I go with what I see from
the conductor or do I go with what I
hear so I very often tell tell
orchestras even York Philharmonic I say
you know I really want you to play with
my bead it's not that I care about
you're following me that precisely it's
just that I want to take the element of
choice out of the question so that
people are not forced to decide okay do
I follow him or do I not all him there
has to be just one current of course
mistakes happen accidents happen if
something goes wrong then you just have
to use your sense and that's based on
experience either you give in sometimes
it's better to give in allow it to sort
of write itself over time other times
you sort of dig your heels in and you
just say okay no this is where it is and
it creates a discomfort an uncomfortable
moment but you try to use your best
sense and I couldn't say it's always one
way or it's always another way you just
have to figure out what the best way to
get out of those situations and
hopefully they're not too frequent